hey guys it is Monday I'm Jeff and I've
got a bit of a confession to make I am
in fact the mysterious fifth wiggle who
dresses all in black and sings about his
ex-girlfriend two toddlers hi missus
gamespy news
[Music]
first up alright I'm kind of breaking
the gamesbut news rule here as this
story sort of came out towards the end
of yesterday but it does involve you
getting free things man love free stuff
don't wheels the official PlayStation
Turkey Twitter channel appears to have
slipped up by tweeting out an image that
suggests that June's PlayStation Plus
offerings are going to be Killing Floor
2 and the life is strange
on ps4 wow really that's an awesome game
I'm so glad people are gonna get a
chance to play it oh man totally the
shooting the gore is so great what you
mean the clevis storytelling in the time
rewind mechanics I think we might be on
different pages they're not unlike the
PlayStation Turkey Twitter page in the
rest of PlayStation the tweet was
removed pretty hastily but this being
the internet neogaf managed to grab it
before it was gone in any case it's
almost the end of the month so we should
get an official announcement from Sony
as to what games we can expect in June
before too long
apologies if you were one of the 69,000
backers to Shenmue threes Kickstarter
back in 2015 it's not going to be at e3
this year Shenmue 3 developer east net
why isn't it yeah I'm not sure
anyway the developer said while our
schedule has yet to be finalized we will
be devoting June to game development and
as a result will unfortunately not to be
participating in any game shows on the
upside the studio did show off a new
character with long hair suspenders and
muscles on his muscles to let us know
what you think in that comment box and
hit the subscribe button so you don't
miss the updates on this one
finally the upcoming Final Fantasy 7
remake has undergone a pretty
significant development change
originally being developed with the help
of external Studios Square Enix has
shifted development to their internal
teams and who's heading up development
Naoki hamaguchi a Final Fantasy veteran
of over a decade who is currently
serving as director for the episodic
Mobius Final Fantasy during a livestream
for the game hamaguchi revealed he had
quote taken charge of the development
and elaborated on the process saying
until now development was moving forward
with external cooperation but the
company has decided to shift to an
internal set up including mass
production
and quality because we want to control
everything including quality on a stable
schedule
don't worry Mobius Final Fantasy fans he
won't be leaving the series the Final
Fantasy 7 remake is coming to ps4 though
no release date has been set that is
everything we've got for you today be
sure to have yourselves a lovely Monday
Tuesday or whatever day it may be while
you're watching this one and we will see
you tomorrow